yo the yo-yo what's up y'all it's your
boy jelly roll and you can check me out
right here on the bootleg cab podcast we
talked about some real stuff we talked
about some funny stuff and we talked
about some goofy stuff this won't be
worth the lesson
you know the good news is i've just
assumed we were rolling well now we're
rolling yay jelly all right we're
[ __ ] here talking about mushroom
gummies we're talking about mushroom
gummies and how i was like i'm gonna
take six he was like yeah just take two
and think so what were you saying about
the type of drugs that you don't mind
carrying i don't mind carrying any drug
that you can ingest
that is like an immediate no problem
it's like the instant solving of the i
don't want to we're getting pulled over
we're stressed out i can solve the
problem
let's everybody just split the pack in
half right and we're [ __ ] we're all
going to be high nobody's going to jail
and we're going to have a wild afternoon
we didn't expect you know what i'm
saying those are the best ones have you
done that where you've eaten drugs
before you got pulled over yes before
the cops even went i never i didn't even
get whipped one time he just followed me
for so long
what were you eating i took some [ __ ]
shrooms oh wow it took like a [ __ ]
whole [ __ ] eighth i mean a whole
[ __ ] quarter i like did the journey
dawg i was just like i was like
he followed me for like 12 minutes i was
like he's whipping me at any moment dude
i don't want to be caught scrambling
when he does so i just
and this son of a [ __ ] just bangs a
hard left on me like he watched me take
him like haha patty have a good
afternoon [ __ ]
aren't those the best highs though
they're like the best drunks like when
you you you go somewhere and you're like
i'm not gonna get drunk tonight and then
you end up yeah i had that this morning
you got drunk this morning yes at 7 15
this morning you want to hear this story
yeah best story ever we go get on our
plane this morning our plane leaves at 7
15 this morning i'm on like two or three
hours of sleep
i am i hate flying you've been a little
sick too i saw i've been a little under
the weather i'm starting to feel better
because i took a steroid pack i sit down
on the plane
and the dude next to me is just cool as
[ __ ] and as soon as i sit down i'm
joking i get on the plane i'm like
you're lucky contestant number one you
get the fat guy next to you today i know
that's what he's thinking right when i'm
standing in the aisle tell me there's
not a plane full of people going please
not me nothing please not me and i'm
like
and i'm like you're it buddy i'm your
guy and i sit down next to him
and across from us is a nice couple
they're a gay couple really nice couple
they're cool they're in we're all
engaging we got a little thing going in
this row
and before the plane takes off the
flight attendant's like if i want to
drink this was a long flight
and i was like
yeah i'll tell you guys tequila he's
like well i got the margarita shooter so
it's like you know he pours me a big
nice margarita
i smack it dude next to me smacks a
vodka and soda this is 7 17 this morning
flight's leaving at 7 20. we're drinking
before the door shut on the plane
the two dudes next to them were like
they get hype they're just like well
they're doing it we'll do it so the two
dudes are like [ __ ] bring us to vodka
sodas
you know how most times you would have a
flight attendant who like
his job is to kind of party police
what's happening
we had the opposite flight attendant he
was a goddamn bartender he would walk
over be like are we drinking or do i
need to twist an arm here or something
fellas like gassing us up we're like
[ __ ] last week on the job yeah it's
like i did find out he's getting off for
like four days
so he's like brings us another drink now
we've just got to the seat belts off and
i'm two margaritas in
i don't drink vodka i just drink tequila
okay the guy goes i'm like that's
getting me into gesture man he was like
the gay dude sweetest dude on earth goes
oh big papa i got you just follow me do
what you did for me give us a double
vodka throw a splash of soda he won't
even notice it'll calm him stomach down
it'll be the best thing to happen to him
these dudes start getting me [ __ ] up
we smacked like six vodkas this dude was
like giving us last call before we drop
when we're descending he's like i can
legally give y'all one more what do you
think and everybody's like hooray
at this point we're all blackout drunk
almost the two dudes behind the couple
are drinking with us now there's another
girl behind them that's participating
like the entire front half of the plane
is now getting just wrecked this is
amazing it's up dude i pulled in like
i don't remember anything about getting
to where we're staying at
any of the sequences that happened from
how we got there who drove us we came
and ate a big breakfast and i kind of
got back on my feet i was just sitting
at the hotel
pounding water when i got your text and
i was like i've almost sobered up enough
to go do this podcast well you're here
yeah sounds like a great morning man is
that not the best buzzes though yeah for
sure i feel like unexpected nights or
unexpected like i feel like when you go
out and you're like i'm getting [ __ ]
up tonight
usually those are the nights you end up
like
regretting yeah you're like oh [ __ ] wake
up with a bad hangover do some dumb [ __ ]
exactly but when you have no when you
don't plan on getting drunk with
you know a couple of gay guys in first
class
get smacked yeah oh we love each other
now we're texting each other we're gonna
go to dinner when we all get back to
nashville we're like friends nice this
is awesome how's uh how's how's
everything with the family how's the
wifey and she's killing it her podcast
is going crazy crushing we should call
the dumb blonde podcast dumb blonde
podcast we should have set it up for you
to do it while she was here yeah she's
killing it she's uh she's really
crushing man she was actually in vegas
this whole week doing doing pods
so she just came over to la and met me
today
nice well yesterday i think she got here
a day before me to shop or some [ __ ] but
are you like
uh because i know what's it about two
years she's been doing it yeah she's
she's the pandemic kind of triggered it
hmm and you're just kind of like you're
like the unofficial like guest like
guest host yeah whenever yeah just
whenever you know what's crazy the [ __ ]
is so popular now she don't need me
when she first started pod and i was
like i would just fill in kind of
whenever and now i'm like can i get on
your [ __ ] podcast
i need a plug i got a record coming out
i got some [ __ ] going on i need to talk
about i gotta like pencil me man
so jelly things are going well
you got jimmy kimmel tomorrow i got
jimmy kimmel dude by the time this is
out i don't know what yeah by the time
this is out he'll be on you'll be able
to go on youtube or watch it
look on some yeah for sure uh
yeah how many plaques do we got now the
last couple of years save me platinum
right save me platinum fall in the falls
gold
creatures gold
same [ __ ] just got its certification
i think to be gold
um
i think the uh
way that a willy two albums close to
being gold is the whole record wow
and i think
a beautiful disaster is closing in on it
because we got like two more records off
a beautiful disaster that are close to
gold and right now
you just got there trying to look like
this [ __ ] place in here bubba it's
happening well for people who don't know
you uh let's give them a rundown i've
known you for about eight nine years but
you are like uh
a veteran for real in this music [ __ ]
you have had many incarnations of your
career
you've had to go sit down for a little
bit yeah get back out but let's break
down like how long
have you been doing this [ __ ] like
i guess how long have you been making
money off of because you started off i
mean obviously you still do rapping
but you're kind of like
people are kind of being introduced to
you as a country guy yeah yeah you've
been doing this for a long time yeah
i had an interesting thing happen to me
just today um a guy seen me
out in hollywood and he was like yo
i heard your song dead man walking on
rock radio i became a fan i love your
stuff
i identified to him as a rock artist
which went number one right yeah i went
number one for multiple weeks my first
number one and
then you fast forward in the airport in
nashville today
i'm taking a picture with a couple
at 6 45 this morning then when somebody
goes by and goes who's that he goes he's
a country artist
you know
but then it's like i'm hanging out with
bootleg keg who knows i'm a rapper right
you know it's so funny when we were
pulling up
all my guys have been with me a long
time you knew a couple of them and i
don't know why i didn't tell them where
we were going i was like yeah we're just
going to do a podcast we pull up i'm
like yo we're going to do we're going to
see bootleg kevin i was like that's the
[ __ ] home he's been following me for
seven years because we met each other
you know
and it was just super cool to see that
so yeah it's been weird we're kind of a
format agnostic that is true but what
was like uh for you like how many years
in is this you did it
what do you mean you did it
you see that you look at him smiling he
knows it you did it you remember i
remember we're eating tacos
outside of saint patrick's taco bell in
saint pete florida in saint pete florida
and we were 14 yeah i was out here in
l.a doing the uh doing doing the shimmy
shuck at the time and trying to figure
it out and i'd had the record sunday
morning yep before uncle cracker was
before uncle cracker was on it when it
was just an acoustic strip down record
and you were like
what the [ __ ] are you doing you was like
go all you just like started preaching
to me at this little taco bus
and you were like bet the farm on this
[ __ ] this is what you need to do this is
it this you were just like
ringing it home i can't remember rich
was with us that time or not but i know
we've seen rich in the same circuit
around that time
and i was like i left there thinking
like
all right [ __ ] it i'm gonna just and i
did i just went all the way in yeah that
sunday morning record was crazy it's
still crazy i wanted to do it so fire i
love that song it's yeah i like the like
the og version that you would just play
me no for sure it was like a real
it was unplugged right it was like just
literally brought in i mean saved me
yeah for sure exactly
literally
i got something i'll play before we
leave i got some [ __ ] i want to play i'm
so excited about oh i bet uh
yeah that was like in 2000 that was like
2014. that was like when you uh what was
the name of that white dude who would
always book all all y'all in in uh saint
pete [ __ ] kev kevin
yeah i just seen big kev when we went
down there and played uh what was the
rock fest um
if we played the rock yeah they're gonna
hate me
[ __ ] forgive me y'all i'm hungover
i'm day hungover
um it's different in the day yeah it's
so different when you got drunk at 9 00
a.m
but
we played no no that we played that one
after that but it was the tampa rock
station
yeah it's rock fest or something
whatever the name of that station was
down there in tampa the rock station
[ __ ] if anybody should know you should
know what's the name of the right it's
only rock station something x 98 x i
think yeah max might have been x fest or
something like that that sounds about
right yeah whatever
yeah hey rhymes we kicked it we had a
ball but anyways yeah we i just i just
seen big kevin came out to see us there
but like i want to kind of give people
like a real idea of like how long this
journey has been for you because like
you were also
independently very successful
before
you and i met you had a following you
know what i'm saying like this [ __ ] is
very it feels like what is it like
20 years in
yo for sure i realized how old i was
listening to you and cassie's podcast
when caskey who's a dude that's been
around for a long time now referenced me
as the first dude he did a song with
yeah and i was like i am [ __ ] old
yeah i was like it's happened i became
him i'm saying
yeah cassie's been around a long time
yeah yeah
so what was like
you remember like what was the first
project what was that year i came
i got released from jail the last time
that i had to do a bid in
2009
okay and i put out the 10 minute
freestyle which we were talking about
off camera that if my p.o asked i hate
drywall
which we still sell those shirts on
jellyroll615.com
and
i remember putting it on youtube my dude
had a flip cam chat arms yeah i just was
watching the youtube video like two
weeks ago yeah we didn't realize the
power of youtube now mind you i was
putting out mixtapes while i was in and
out of jail before that old school yeah
cd spindles you were part of this era
like we're running around passing out
five dollars like straight off the
spindle handwritten jelly roll
right
so i did that and then my introduction
to the internet
was about 2009
and he filmed that 10-minute freestyle
and uploaded it
and it went
crazy especially for that error because
then me and little white ended up doing
pop another pill because white had
reached out to me right after i got out
of jail
and then we did the snow project with
juicy j and dj paul and project pad and
we had all that history with 36 mafia at
that time
and all that stuff we were doing
and i remember me and little white has
shot to pop another pill video of mike
busey and panama city beach sean mike
busey this is back when
world star hip-hop was god
right
we submitted it to world star hip-hop
and i'll never forget this they said hey
man we only post videos that go viral
first time i heard the word viral
and we were like well define viral and
in the email back they said 30 000 views
in a week
on youtube that's it that's how info you
still had to go to a desktop computer
and type in www.youtube.com
yeah you know what i'm saying so it's
like it was in such it's infant stages
that they're we ended up doing 50 000
views in three days so they put it on
world star
and that was the beginning of that
that was like one of my first eras you
know what i'm saying
damn i feel like post jail you don't
count like the seven mixtapes i did how
long were you in jail
every time was a different amount of
time from 14 to 24 probably seven and a
half to eight years [ __ ] so just kind of
in and out
do a year come home for six months do a
year come home for four months dude
[ __ ]
everything from you know i don't i'm not
yeah i'm not proud of any of it it's
public information so well it's good
that you know yeah but everything from
gun charges to drugs to a robbery case
do you remember like uh what because you
know you know people like this i know
people like this that have potential
that are talented but for whatever
reason they just get stuck in that
back into jail it's the revolving door
of the judicial system like what was the
breaking point for you where you were
like nah this is enough i got to get my
[ __ ] on track it's so cool talking to
you because we know each other so
personally you know but it was my
daughter yeah bailey was born in 2008 so
one of those times where i was out of
jail i had gotten a young woman pregnant
okay and then bailey was born while i
was in jail
and then the old southern baptist term
that was my damascus road experience
where saul turned to paul
i'll never forget i was in like the gang
unit like the like worst dorm you could
be in in jail at the time [ __ ] because i
was just running the poker table and
gambling and not you know i was just
[ __ ] doing time
and the day they knocked on my door and
told me bailey was born i signed up to
go to the education unit try to get my
ged i don't know what just like i
scrambled out of nowhere i was just like
i got to figure this [ __ ] out right now
and i ended up having to do like another
year but whenever i came home you know
it was a game changer that was it we
started off to the races
yo uh you're like uh you know i feel
like
the rock taps in with a lot of artists
that i happen to know but he really
[ __ ] with you it's my dude is that not
awesome the rock has been [ __ ] with
you like for like five six years now
it's crazy like he posts your [ __ ] all
the time all the time
he is just he's a nashville dude at
heart
loki he's like
he traveled so much as a child
that he has a lot of places he's really
connected with and by luck of the beast
nashville is one of them
so he really kind of connects to our
scene and culture like he gets guys like
me like and he told me earlier he was
like yo
i know guys like you from nashville so
man you had this talk early like
nashville was kind of famous for that
white boy trap rap [ __ ] yeah it was like
uh yourself was haystack from hashtag
for sure nashville boy he was ahead of
us haystack kind of led the charge on
that and
there was so many you know we had a band
before haystack called rude awakening
chris taylor which is like an uncle or
cousin of ours me and my brother and
it's like the white's from nashville
little white's from memphis down the
street in tennessee it's all that kind
of you know
so he was like i get the culture of the
city he's like people won't get it at
first but trust me it'll it'll work yeah
because there was like this like
nashville white boy dope boy [ __ ] going
on that like like you said it was very
like you had to
be from there to really understand
like what kind of dudes you were at the
time for sure which is why we popped in
florida because florida so many white
boys like that too yeah yeah yeah so
it's like when you went to st pete you
were just like it was a town full of
them yeah you know or largo or all that
stuff the old gasoline alley bar we
played down there back in the day the
thug crackers the thug crackers you know
what i'm saying you remember this so it
was like caskey cask there were so many
kids that was that that culture came so
like florida and
georgia the south especially just
immediately in the midwest indiana ohio
they love you in ohio oh dude it's like
first market ever for us it's like
second home for me still hey we gotta
stop the interview real quick to tell
you about our family our good folks at
odd socks you see me look
these are the odd socks basics on my
skinny white [ __ ] legs
i love odd socks go to odd
oddssocksofficial.com
you're going to get 20 off at checkout
if you use the promo code bootleg kev
that's one word bootleg kev now they got
odd socks which are great my favorites
are the basics they also you know you
got the license one these are the
twizzlers these are baywatch socks but
then you got the basics now these are
what these are
just the plain boys man
they're so comfy all right i always got
the white basics the black basics on and
i always got odd socks underwear on too
they got the draws all right so what are
you doing go to oddssocksofficial.com
use the promo code
bootslag kev save 20 off check out these
[ __ ] draws kool-aid
underwear ladies and gentlemen what are
we doing odd socks official dot com
bootleg kev is the promo code save 20
off right now let's get back to the
interview
ohio is like a
it's a weird place man it's because it's
like in the middle of the country it's
like not quite like the south but it
feels very like
it kind of feels like a
country place sort of yeah well you know
what it is when you've you go 30 miles
outside of any of the major metropolises
in ohio and you might as well be in
mississippi
it's that fast i mean you're in
cincinnati and then you blink your eye
and you're in [ __ ] south mississippi
that's crazy you're like what the [ __ ]
just happened
it's insane but it's bred its own
culture up there in sound too
yeah for sure oh so shout out to doobie
immediate hill and highlight have
pioneered an entire culture out of
columbus i met dube for the first time
when he was running around on the road
with you yeah in st pete florida that's
another thing that came up in an
interview of yours where i was like i'm
[ __ ] old
i mean you know you ain't that old god
if you [ __ ] make me feel it when you
interview these young dudes you're like
yo i met you 10 years ago with jelly i'm
like [ __ ] i'm old well you know what's
great is
you're now making country music which
country and rock music i feel like it
doesn't matter how old you are it's
definitely timeless i swear rap music i
feel like you know you're gonna always
have a niche audience but
hip hop is all about what's new what's
next you know i was telling somebody
what i'm anxious to see
is the um
i watched
the mount westmore tour come to
nashville
and sell out the bridgestone arena
thirteen thousand seven hundred seconds
yep
and then i watched the legends of the
street tour
come to nashville jeezy gucci tv yeah
sell out booze sell out 13 700 tickets
it's the first time in our in life that
we're seeing hip-hop translate
generationally right and like oldies
hip-hop for sure because like back in
the day that's what they'd say this will
never make it to arenas nobody will care
to see this show in 20 years
and people are seeing it
i want to see in 20 years from now
if little dirk
and little baby and the baby can go sell
15 000 tickets in every major market in
america right time will tell you it's
gonna be fun to watch dude it's like a
student of the game because hip hop is
so
young
when you think about it not even from
the kids doing it like just to think
that ice cubing them was our first
reference point of watching hip hop grow
with people to the point that i just
watched 13 000 white kids it's like we
in their [ __ ] 40s what's singing
everywhere those guys are like are
they're
the first generation of hip-hop guys to
be 50. yeah
you know what i mean it's crazy right
yeah i didn't think about it till i was
there and i was like this is nuts yeah
like dude i was born when nwa was
getting active oh yeah i was born in 87.
yeah for sure so i'm born a little bit
before that but yeah i was born a little
bit more now
just a little bit not much not a ton of
hair
what's been like um
you know since you've kind of been on
this run the last couple of years what
has been the coolest thing that you've
got to experience because you've showed
out some big shows you've been a part of
like some crazy
you've just been i mean you're about to
do jimmy kimmel tomorrow you know like
what's been some something that's where
you just kind of had to pinch yourself
one of those moments where you're like
damn this is pretty [ __ ] cool
uh
the first time that when we got invited
to the granola library um was just
the history of the grand ole opry and
i'm letting somebody that represents our
community and our kind
and our culture
you know because like regardless of how
much i mess the music together i'm a
hip-hop kid
and i'll always will be i'm a student of
the game i love hip-hop
and i was the first rapper to play the
grand ole opry even though i sung right
right it's like still there's a thing
there
um
the first local rapper because
nashville's had a lot of big talent come
out to sell out the ramen of course yeah
we're we are like
35 no [ __ ] tickets away from selling
out red rocks in october
so that's a that's in denver yeah you
got to come out october 23rd
it's going to be nuts you're headlining
that's going to be crazy yeah almost
sold out
and we're playing you know we're
headlining my arena in nashville you
seen this part you seen this i saw it
yeah this is crazy so we're gonna
headline that's another one that was
they're all wow moments yeah i saw that
big show you did last year in dallas
that looked [ __ ] crazy insane no for
sure we just sold
seven thousand tickets at a hockey arena
sold out in kalamazoo the day of the on
sale that [ __ ] is troublesome just
played it the other day it was [ __ ]
nuts i just did 20 000 people at
tailgates and tall boys co-headlining
with riley
just every everything about us just like
what in the [ __ ] is happening what are
the things that you're noticing um
being in the country industry now
because it is you've lived in nashville
so i'm sure it's not it's never been too
far away but it's a different game like
i feel like country is one of the i know
people who do country radio
and they get treated like [ __ ]
royalty yeah by the artist and by by
like the labels it's crazy well
you know
people still buy cds people don't
realize countries still
the only cities getting sold at walmart
country cds what i love about country
music is
is it's very tribal
there's a lot of people who find music
through country radio and through the
just country music
it's like
they're still a country music fan
that exists it's like just a fan of
country music so if they know that you
do country music they're just in they're
gonna at least give you a chance they're
gonna give you a chance they're like oh
[ __ ] i love country music you make
country music play me something yeah
where it's like in hip-hop it's like
everybody raps
this is true every everybody everybody
raps trust me i just left an empire
brunch shout out to empire
bro i couldn't walk two feet with
someone stopping me and just
no for sure it was just like hey yo i
rap yeah i get on the pod hey yo what's
up yo yo and you're just like
no it's there's a lot everybody raps so
it's like when you tell the dude hey man
i rap let me play you something instead
of them being like i'd like to listen
they go i rap too
and you're just like oh there that went
you know you know yeah but you don't
need a lot of country artists
i mean unless you're in nashville in
nashville exactly you throw a rock and
hit one but it's like there's a core
country music fan
and i've always been a country music fan
just because you grew up in nashville
you can't help but to be mm-hmm there's
no way that yeah i mean country i feel
like um
obviously i'm a big hip-hop dude but
like
just like with any genre of music
there's [ __ ] i like right you know what
i mean you know halite said it to me
best
when this [ __ ] started working for me he
said
i'm watching you finally do what i
watched you
do in the car for 10 years he's like and
it's so gratifying
because we would get in the car and go
on these long road trips and i would
just torture them with
george strait records and billy
currington songs and i'm like blair like
i'm doing sound check singing darius
rucker every day that's [ __ ] great
you know and the highlight was like it's
so cool like everybody who really knows
what kind of music i listen to
thought it was super dope to finally see
me you know okay this is like you know
you doing what we see you do in the car
anyways like we watch you smoke weed and
sing alan jackson so this is cool
are you gonna get into some [ __ ]
movies or something man dude i just
talked to a guy got something on my
sleeve because dude or like tv or you
should host a [ __ ] i don't know i
just feel like you just got to be on the
on the screen man i feel like it too i
feel like this handsome face
deserves a chance
no i think we're gonna do something i
gotta you know i'm really inspired by
what mgk's doing right now oh yeah he
did his own movie he's just doing his
own movies they're [ __ ] incredible
for sure shout out to my what a genius
great guy man i'd love to meet him plug
us in if you can i'm surprised you never
met him
you know what's crazy i know what's
crazy i talked to mgk the other day and
i was like
i should have asked him then i should be
like yo just throw me in a mod in the
text just randomly i just love to yeah
he's great reach out i just i'm such a
fan of his spirit and his music his
writing ability you know just the way
he's a great creative he's a great
creative man that's another thing like
think about the rock [ __ ] it's crazy
like all these artists like like mgk
obviously very incredible rapper
but god damn he's a [ __ ]
arena tour right now it's wild man
he's
on the phone drunk facetiming the other
night and he was like
you know he was talking about my
daughter had got me a little billboard
for father's day which was so cool i saw
that yeah it was the sweetest thing ever
and it's just the dad and him that
identified that you know
and i'm like he's like you [ __ ]
how are you you know what a billboard
i'm like you got a [ __ ] helicopter in
an arena every night that carries you
across fourteen thousand people
[ __ ] my billboard oh so you're tripping
that dude is on top of the world right
now you know and he's still the same kid
from cleveland that we all talked to
when he was you know doing what was a
thousand words and running or whatever
yeah he's still the same kid pushing the
lace-up mixtape when you talk to him how
diverse is like
because like when you have a show now
and you're selling 13 000 tickets or 7
000 tickets
like
how much of the crowd is like og jelly
fans and how much just found you
recently it's a good split you know the
cool thing about catalogs are and i
always hear russ talk about this and i
understand it now
is that you can only build a true core
base with a catalog
right
um
sometimes guys will have songs that'll
get really hot
and the song will blow up there's no
catalog to back it so you have people
that want to be a fan of you but they
don't have enough catalogue to be a fan
of yours got you yeah cause like they
might go to the one song and be like i
like this but what else is there and the
dudes got two eps out right
you know
where it's like guys like myself have
you have someone if someone hears your
song on the radio and they go to your
spotify page they might just dive into
you just get
god willing you get lost in the jelly
roll rabbit hole yeah just give me a
chance give me a three song chance
and if i can get you with those three i
think i can suck you in the mirror i've
played save me for hundreds of people
oh yes that's my favorite song for sure
ever it's like i told you when i first
was like brother [ __ ] no it's
it's it's a it's like one of those
records that
i can listen to it
i don't listen like i don't write around
bumping just your own [ __ ] yeah but not
if i'm in the car it's a perfect song
man i'm like yo let that [ __ ]
ring like that you know that slaps are
you guys going to rework it
we got a plan
i have a vision i had a dream and like a
real dream to put like god willing
i just want to put like
adele on it oh
and i'm just speaking that into
existence and it sounds really wild but
could you imagine adele coming in with
what if the night sky
was missing the moon
you know [ __ ] adele it's like
somebody who feels that kind of pain
yeah because i feel like that's a record
that like obviously it's been out a
couple of years but
if you worked it to radio now or
whatever right be [ __ ] a layup
i know this sounds weird but
for me music helps people yeah right
is that my people yes they're fine
it didn't pick up awesome yeah you're
good you're good the mics are super okay
cool yeah i'm like only my people would
come in and start shooting dice in there
or something like that this is our
moment we want to play celo
to me it's like music helps people
and it's not even about the monetary
value of the song for me
it's about how can i get it in front of
more people because i know how many
people it's helped
you know what i mean i know how many
people have came to me through addiction
struggles losing family members
mental health
just drunk nights of sadness that are
like save me was the song for me it's
like how can you get a song that helps
that many people in front of more people
it's kind of my goal so it's like i want
to do whatever i can to get in front of
the world and a lot of your music has
those kind of messages i guess you know
what i'm saying it's not like
i mean
your music is very personal to you yeah
it's very cathartic yeah it's
therapeutic it's
i always wanted to make music with a
very i'm very intentional in my
songwriting
do you now that you're popping or is
like the label trying to put you in with
writers are you just straight handling
everything for sure you're obviously
sick with the pen for sure or on the
other side you're in nashville now
you're kind of known as a guy now are
you helping other people with writing
i'm doing some of that yeah i'm doing
some of that and and the cool thing is
as a fan of writers
like kells and mod getting in a room
together
i have gotten a room with some people
that i wanted to get in the room of
course you know that i was like yo i
love the way this is collaborate yeah
like i would be honored to write a song
with that
so hip hop has trained us to be like
in your own little bubble write your own
[ __ ] you know what i mean and it's like
where every other genre is way more open
to being like it's not even about
somebody else helping write your lyrics
it's about sometimes i'll go help
another dude right right and just me
being in there helps whenever he's just
like am i tripping or is this [ __ ]
dope
and just me being like that's dope
sometimes yeah sometimes it's like
if you're in there with someone you
respect and they give you some
affirmation that you appeared yeah or
sometimes i just put people back on the
right path like you'll have a dude
noodling and he'll catch something and
then get away you know how you knew
you've been in the studio some dudes was
in there humming and noodling and he
came sorry when you said noodling i'm
thinking jumping into a lake and
catching cats catching cat fish yo we
can go with hannah baron any day you
want to go she invited me and the wife
out have you seen hannah baron no but
i've seen people noodle on youtube oh
dude
have you ever me and the wife that have
you ever noodled yes [ __ ] yeah explain
absolutely wait a minute
so what is this noodling thing oh it's
real so catfish are and i'm gonna
butcher it hannah don't judge me
but catfish normally are in like holes
right shallower holes and what you do is
you kind of
fish into the hole and the catfish by
instinct will bite
and then you pull the catfish out but
bite your hand yeah
right does it hurt well i mean it's not
it's not
comfortable but it's not like you know
it's not a barracuda right so it's like
but yeah so if you look at people that
get big [ __ ] fists they'll have scars
on their arms and [ __ ] so you've
actually done this i've actually brought
one out of the water you've you've
caught a catfish with your bare hands
bare hands brought it out and felt like
[ __ ] thor held it up over my head
like here you hear you people of
whoville i'm the [ __ ] dude
you like have to bash it in the head to
kill it no no it's just like any other
fish you hold it out of water long
enough it'll die
give it a slow death
torture right [ __ ] you we're not putting
it out of your misery and now peter
cancels me yo
so do you cook the fish yeah i love
catfish oh man oh it's i don't
not that i'm weird about stuff but i
would if i'm either playing catch and
release or i'm frying something
nice and that's my role and catfish is
one of my favorite things to eat so
noodling i'm i've watched a lot of that
on youtube what was the name of that one
redneck kid who was rolling around with
yellow for a while camo camo i used to
love seeing him or whatever yep his
instagram page because he would have the
most as well he had like a pet possum
running around on his shoulder yeah you
gotta follow hannah barrett i'm gonna
send her your page now it is
campbell on steroids she's catching
cheryl from like south alabama that
pulls out catfish the size of you she's
catching snakes she's like [ __ ] five
to like 110. she's pulling out fists
that are bigger than her it's [ __ ]
wild
is there good money in that you think i
don't i know her youtube channel crushes
i mean that's that's there's great money
yeah
i've been getting stuck in um
i've been watching van life youtube
videos oh i can't get off of that that
and puppies are all my tic toc is van
life and uh tiny homes yeah i hadn't
gotten into the tiny homes but the van
life [ __ ] has well warped me the van
life [ __ ] it makes me like sometimes
fantasize about having no kids and being
single right oh watch out and just being
on an island i'm gonna go live in my van
save up all this money piss in the park
oh you're in a slippery slope my friend
you should somebody should reel you away
from this fast that's where it starts
going south he starts selling mushrooms
me and my you know me and my wife like
we'll go to the dollar store sometimes
and i'll just be looking at like the
groceries i'd be like man i tell my wife
i'm like man if i was single i [ __ ]
that bologna up for a dollar
do you want to be single i'm like no i
was just thinking in my head if i was
like single with a one-bedroom apartment
like this is where i'd be at if i was in
the van that i really want to be in
besides with you i love that baloney
i just love i don't know make me happy
what about tv what are you streaming
lately uh on tv
oh dude i've been in the middle of all
kind of good [ __ ] have you seen the
offer yet i've heard about it the uh
godfather it's some paramount it's
[ __ ] i couldn't quit watching it
i watched the lincoln lawyer have you
seen the boys uh-uh on amazon's fire i
watch it though you know what i just
caught up on i know i'm late to the
party and i heard it's an unpopular show
out this way but
winning time oh i heard it's great it
was fire people love it it was what
about you're like yellowstone oh yeah
yellowstone is great you guys sucked me
into yellowstone oh it's the best you
gotta get like a [ __ ] cameo i know i
just want to be like one you gotta be
someone in the bunk house yeah or the
bunk house or the bar yeah you're gonna
go to the bar and there's just some dude
you'll be fighting rip yeah that's it
just get beat up by ripping an episode
whoops everybody he's unfucking defeated
i love yellowstone no i couldn't at
first i was against it i was protesting
it silently because i felt like it was
too dialogue driven and my wife's like
trust me i love it i was like i don't
need to get into a show that's like just
a bunch of talking
and then
after the episode i was like
[ __ ] up for a day
i didn't do it i cancelled sessions it
was bad i watched
every season i could catch up on like
three days that she actually had me like
looking up flights to go to houston go
to the rodeo
you should come to frontier days in
wyoming i'm playing a rodeo me co wetzel
and nelly are playing one night
cheyenne frontier days is like a really
really big deal it's like one of the
biggest rodeos on earth like one of the
oldest ones ever wow yes okay
wyoming yeah shine's got his ranch come
on dude have you heard you can still
make cheyenne baby that's an old old
george train song
um
talk about just like
in your opinion man
when you have a level of success that
you're kind of experiencing
does it feel like it or because
sometimes we don't realize that we're
living in the moment we're living in
until it's like two or three years later
like damn like are you lit are you
enjoying the moment are you like really
like appreciating just everything going
on right now oh more than i've ever
appreciated anything
i am so conscious of where i am in my
life
i'll give you an example
the other day when we had those three
string of shows we had three shows in a
row they're all just like killer shows
i literally just handed my phone to my
dude on the beginning of the weekend and
said hey man just
hand it to me and my wife calls
wow
i didn't touch my phone for 72 hours
unless he was bringing it to me going
your wife's on the phone or your
daughter's on the phone that's fire i
just want to be
there
you know what i'm saying like i want to
be in
every moment i can i want to feel
everything i want to talk to everybody
at this arena
i want to have every conversation you
know i walk the building i have a thing
where i walk the whole building before
the show
i walk it after the show
you know what i mean like i just want to
know i want to feel how it feels before
and after because one it's wild
yeah i mean i think when you start
selling those that amount of tickets
those capacities when you've been doing
like this
you've been on the [ __ ] road oh yeah
doing any size venue you can think of oh
for sure you gotta take that in man me
dooby
before dooby even me and highlight and
god rest his soul big mike
literally lived
in a van with scary larry
and casey in a band a van like a 96
you've seen that van yeah you've seen
the old white van we call it bertha
for
five years
200 some days a year when i met my wife
i didn't have a house
wow i met my wife in 2015 2016 i did not
have an apartment
i was living in the van i was home so
little that when i was home i would you
find it i would stay [ __ ] family i
would crash couches yeah
and [ __ ] drive to the next city a
couple days early and crash in the van
or get hotels like i didn't even there
was no point in even having a
you know we did that for so long 200 cap
rooms 300 cap rooms thousand cat rooms
400 cat rooms 150 cap rooms we i've
opened up for metal bands i've opened up
for icp multiple times twisted multiple
times the grind of this [ __ ]
god i'm glad we're talking about this
the grind of this [ __ ] is what people
miss the most
right is the years
and you do me and you talk about all the
time privately how proud i am of you
thank you that like we were the same two
dudes in tampa that were trying to
figure it out the next thing i know
you're [ __ ]
in la right you're [ __ ]
meet the love of your life your [ __ ]
[ __ ] running the ranks up again
you're [ __ ]
biggest market in america you're
figuring this [ __ ] out it's like that's
our dude yeah like that's how we've
always identified you like that's our
[ __ ] guy that's our dude that's
figuring that [ __ ] out you know what i
mean it's like when a country does uh
security for juicy mm-hmm and when we
pull up here he's like oh blew that
cable that kid yeah juicy level they can
yeah i'm like everybody [ __ ] you know
everybody's on this podcast i was like
i've been harassing kev to get on this
podcast you know what i mean yeah but
it's one of those things where they
don't
the grinds of years and years and years
of eating [ __ ] sandwiches to finally get
a [ __ ] philly cheesesteak
what do you think it was for you because
you obviously got new management but i
feel like you've done something that is
very hard to do
and
when
you come up on the underground tip like
you do
and you gain a lot of fan bases from a
lot of different artists like you said
you opened up for icp twisted all that
you obviously heavily affiliated with
strange music they distributed at least
one of your projects that's right
distributed too travis uh you went on a
whole tour with tech i went out with
yellow wolf twice yeah it's like you
have um kind of all these fans and
you know they come from all different
walks of life but
there is like a stigma that comes with a
lot of those fan bases and even
when we think of
the white rapper thing right it feels
like the ice the underground white
wrapper thing it's like a hard mold to
get out of
and i feel like you've busted through it
it's like you're just jelly roll and and
i i focused on making music that was
real not music that was cool
because there was moments like when i'm
playing you sunday morning you get it
but it wasn't cool
it was the opposite and it wasn't what
people was working yeah russell wasn't
what you're known for what you were
putting out at all yeah it's like i just
focused on the music that felt real like
to this day it's like i know that i'm
not
going to connect with some of the people
because it's not trendy it's not cool
it's just not the texture of sound
they're looking for
but strip it down it's real
it might not be real to you and it might
not be what you're looking for but this
is i feel authentic in everything i do
i'm not chasing cool i'm not
overthinking visuals i'm not trying to
package something in a way that's just
like
i'm just putting out music that feels
right yeah
to where i'm at in that moment of my
life dude i'm sitting here you know talk
about my age all day but i'm a 37 year
old man
i'm on the verge of being 38 i have a 14
year old daughter that'll be 15 and six
months she's a [ __ ] high schooler
crazy my son's 16 yeah inevitably i was
going to start making a different kind
of music right obviously you're not the
same [ __ ] guy yeah i'm not even close
so it's like i just whatever felt real
to where i am in my life at that moment
and to the people i know who i'm writing
songs for
i'm still writing songs for my mother
wow right i'm still writing songs for
that woman who's struggling with
addiction struggling financially
[ __ ] pain in her eyes trying to
figure out how to take care of her kids
i'm still writing songs for that woman
and i'm still writing songs for that
dude in that trailer park or that
apartment or that [ __ ] run-down house
or a middle-class neighborhood that's
busting his ass and working his ass off
and trying to figure life out i'm still
writing songs for that dude that's
[ __ ] selling weed on the side because
his job's not paying enough to take care
of his family
i'm still writing songs for that dude on
that back road in that little country
[ __ ] town
and that pickup truck that he busted his
ass to get the smokes at joint every day
the moment he gets off work i know who
the [ __ ] i'm writing songs for right
you know
i'm not trying to write a song for
[ __ ] the kids that went to rolling
loud this year
you know what i'm saying and i'm very
honest about that yeah it's fair of
course not yeah so it's like
knowing that was my my busting point i
tell people all the time you can't i'll
see a jelly roll fan before he sees me
every time
and i'm [ __ ] fat with tattoos on my
face i stand the [ __ ] out and i'll still
watch that guy walk into a grocery store
and go
that's my guy
for sure that's my guy i'll catch that
guy in a minute i'll tell my wife that's
our guy right there
two hours later holy [ __ ] jelly dude i
[ __ ] love your [ __ ] i'm like thanks
man i knew it yeah and every now and
then i'll walk by a dude that i think's
my guy and he's not and i'll introduce
myself
hey man i know that sounds weird dude
but dude i just feel like i [ __ ]
speak for you i know i don't know you
from the moon i'm not trying to
stereotype you in your house but [ __ ]
i make [ __ ] kind of rock and roll
[ __ ] southern rap country music and
[ __ ] and i just think you'd [ __ ] with it
that's so crazy hey let's take a quick
piss break cause i'm about to piss on
myself yes can i get a water in the piss
break or is this a waterless facility
we're going to go get you a water
boulet kev podcast got to stop things
real quick tell you about our good folks
at blue chew listen fellas if you're
trying to get your dick right you're
trying to stay harder
everyone wants to be hard can you stay
hard
you know what i mean
if you need some help with your dick is
essentially what i'm trying to say
you need to go to bluetooth.com and get
down with uh something that i feel like
is imperative and having yourself a
lovely evening with a lovely young lady
or male whatever you're into if you go
to bluetooth.com you will get a blue
chew it has the same active ingredient
as cialis and his viagra
right but guess what it doesn't have the
awkward doctor visits that's right you
don't got to wait in line at some lobby
to go get you some [ __ ] [ __ ] to get
your dick working and have some awkward
conversation with a nurse and then have
an awkward conversation with a doctor
and then he writes you a prescription
and then you go to the pharmacist and
then it's awkward because you pass them
the prescription and everyone knows
you're picking up dick stuff you know
what i'm saying no blue chew you go to
the website it's all online it gets sent
straight to your house in discrete
packaging in a chewable form listen your
first month free
right now when you go to bluechew.com
and you use the promo code bootleg
that's right you get the first month for
free bluetooth.com
promo code
bootleg
thank me later all right go get your
dick together fellas yo i'll get you uh
it's crazy how they did the media base
and the platinum record in one yeah i'll
put it right here so it's on camera yeah
i'll get you one of those for a free
billboard every episode oh yeah for
[ __ ] dead man walking
oh because we got the radio thing for it
too i just got
we we cried we cracked the top 25 this
week home country wow 24 as of today
move two slots again
are you finding that country's a little
harder it's way harder the chart's a lot
harder it's [ __ ] it's harder than any
other genre on earth it's also got the
biggest audience besides pop but as i
say
but reach is way more
and pop has only got a bigger audience
by like
it's closed kev
i can imagine it's kind of blew my mind
if you think about like
how big the middle of the country is
compared to the metropolis parts it's
like right most of this [ __ ] is
for sure no 100
i had perspective the other day we were
leaving nashville and i was driving the
tailgates and tall boys the first
festival
and it was like
two hours like
i think i was two and a half hours
outside of nashville and i was still
picking up the nashville country radio
station wow like literally i was in
kentucky
and i was clearly picking up 1033.
yo
what hap uh one of my favorite things
that happened during the pandemic was
you and andrew song
dude it was so funny the video was so
good it was my favorite thing that
happened to the [ __ ] coven anthem it
was the covenant anthem dude i tell
people me and andrew scholes are
responsible for the country opening back
up i don't care what nobody says that
[ __ ] was so good it was so and you know
what his whole team is just [ __ ]
awesome you talk about a dude who gets
it oh he gets it he gets it he's the
best he's
if
rappers would take one
twentieth of his approach
to the business
he's kind of doing the rust thing very
just do it yourself with your comedy
side put it out as much as you can
overload the content constantly drops
but my favorite thing about what he does
is how he presents it yeah he's not
afraid to spend the dollar for the good
look yeah this is inside baseball but
when i watch him played la here right
he rents the old 6-4 yeah he shoots the
footage of him pulling up to the theater
with it bouncing those little things man
little things that are just like
you thought about
you know it's like
when we came down here to do the kimmel
thing
and they sent us over the production
stuff my first question was cool can i
build a set
right
you know it's like i know they're not
paying and i know that at that point
i've got to pay to build the set and
break the set down but it's like can i
build a set yeah you know what i mean
like i want to make sure that what we do
i mean look that's that's a look that
you might get once in your lifetime ever
i mean hopefully it's one of many of
those looks but you just never know
right so it's like yeah you know that's
going to reach millions of people yeah
like teddy swims and megan trainer just
built a garden on kimmel or what i just
saw i like teddy swimsuit i love teddy
swim so much and he's it was so good to
just like to see him like go thank you
just doing amazing do you have to go to
a store to get this it's next door oh
dude i'm so sorry i would have never
asked you to go buy me a water um just
the teddy swims guys so down dude
he's also just like us
he was covering all kinds of ill arm b
[ __ ] like mario let me love you and i
don't care how much of a singer i think
i am i hear him singing i want to quit
you guys link up at all oh yeah we
talking nashville all the time we
wouldn't got drunk at the rhyme a few
weeks ago
he's a nashville guy yeah but he lives
there now
he's a georgia kid
yeah nashville's like uh
if you're in for people who don't know
obviously music city but like if you're
in the country music industry
like you have to be there almost you
have to you can't make it anywhere else
if you want to be a part of the pop
country scene now texas has its own
country scene in general just like it
had its own rap scene it's no different
texas is like that for all music
but yeah if you want to be a part of but
even the texas people got to move to
nashville right if they want to go big
yeah they want to go bigger than texas
um
uh when did you help andrew write his
portion of that record yeah it was a
collaborative right but scholes is he's
very clever so i'm not sure he like i'm
sure he's got the funny lines he had all
the lines we just had to keep him in
rhythm
the best part was when he was like all
right i want to sing it i was like what
that's not what i seen coming you know
you guys shot that video in florida
right yeah we went down to florida when
they were doing this uh flagrant in
miami thing oh we had a blast when i got
pissed drunk
we had a [ __ ] ball dude you obviously
i see you pop up on a lot of podcasts
like a shout out to theo vaughn shout
out to brandon schaub and those guys
um would you ever have your own podcast
is that something that you even think
you have time to
even dabble in
i've been talking to a company about it
and i'd like to i love podcasting one i
just love the idea of
conversation
but two
i just love the idea of just being goofy
so i love doing like theo and shobb and
which
i think i would do the king and the
sting again this week and i think i'm
gonna do
the fighting the kid with shavon callum
this week
and this is my big one and i hope it
works out but as of right now it's on
the books for me to do the burp cast oh
i love bert yeah i'm so excited i'm such
a bird fan so if i get to actually do
chrysler i'm gonna [ __ ] lose my [ __ ]
they're supposed to be making a movie
based on the machine thing for sure
literally he went out there and shot it
already yeah he's so funny he's so
[ __ ] funny you know it's funny
because when i first said saw his [ __ ]
and i saw he did a stand-up with no
shirt on i was like i have some gimmicky
[ __ ] then i actually watched it i was
like oh this guy's [ __ ] guy
well the best part is then you watch him
and that's just who he is yeah for sure
you know he's got the most like
hilariously painful laugh oh yeah for
sure like when he laughs oh it's like
you don't know for sure
it's like it's
like painful like bro it's like someone
are you okay like he's gonna stroke out
yeah like he's super red-faced yes
what's something that you learned uh you
had a great pandemic i had a great
pandemic in terms of just
where we were before we started to where
we are now what is uh something that you
took away from
you know the goofy era of our country
or the world rather the world yeah
content is king
guys like shoals watching how they
released
um content is also recession proof it's
pandemic proof for sure it's
in fact it's needed more in those
moments yeah people were running out of
[ __ ] to watch oh for sure i read through
a whole little netflix i watched this
oh yeah no for i went back and
re-watched prison break i was just at
the crib just losing my [ __ ]
yeah i was [ __ ] awesome when it first
came it's like every other thing the
first season got weird yeah they got
weird season three they all do broke
right he's even
they end up in jail again in colombia
yeah i'm like how many [ __ ] times can
you end up in [ __ ] jail yeah jesus
y'all milked the drunk utter dry son one
and two spitting does so good so good
they gotta quit [ __ ] legacies up
another show that was like that oh
dexter got weird after season four
the new dexter
was equal what'd you think about the new
dexter was all right i appreciate i
liked it because i hated the way dexter
ended yeah it was so corny so i was kind
of glad that they kind of
brought it back full circle did you ever
see dynasty or whatever it's called um
[Music]
that might have been what it was called
it was a show about a family who like
had a big dynasty and
it's like it was awesome i got to look
at it i mean my wife watched it it was
so good like season three it turned into
a [ __ ] musical
literally these [ __ ] turned this
[ __ ] show that was like savage
gangster cutthroat business [ __ ] and a
[ __ ] musical and i was like y'all
[ __ ] blew it i think five is the
sweet spot
if you really go you gotta end it at
five for sure all the best shows the
wire was five seasons breaking bad was
five seasons ozark four but two parts
right
yeah because i think after you did how
many was sons of anarchy
too many was it like seven it was like
seven or eight yeah
but it was great
it still i loved it you know the way we
knew it would but i just sons of anarchy
when peg bunny stabs uh dax's [ __ ] uh
[ __ ] wife in the head his baby mom oh
my god yeah
she was a
you watch mayans
no i got a couple of friends who play on
it that are awesome joseph and them were
really good i heard it's really good too
yeah i'm [ __ ] with yellowstone
there's a new show with jeff bridges
called the old man that's crazy three
episodes in
is it already all out or is it coming no
it's once a week [ __ ] call me when it's
finished the big lebowski is in it i've
been [ __ ] myself getting into those
things and i'm on the road so i always
miss when it comes out dude the boys
season three starts with this [ __ ]
superhuman dude like there's like people
in the show with powers it's about
essentially it's like
uh
if superheroes were real right they'd be
like corrupt they'd have drug problems
they'd be [ __ ] [ __ ] they'd be like
taking advantage of people like so it's
like that angle the superhero thing
and like the captain america of the show
like the like the biggest superhero in
the country is like a [ __ ] sociopath
serial killer
[ __ ] rapist maniac
and everyone's scared of him because
he's got like what's this show yeah it's
called the boys it's on amazon prime
it's amazing but season three starts
there's this like dude who's kind of
like ant-man right yeah so he's [ __ ]
some gay club
and he takes his dude into the room and
it looks like he's about to get [ __ ]
in the ass
and uh
the the dudes are descriptive so the
dude the dude bends over
and it's like jump in yeah so the
superhero guy
goes super tiny like oh small enough and
he dives in the tip of this guy's dick
no [ __ ] way so he's inside of the
guy's dick yeah and he's like tickling
the sides and when he sneezes he gets
big again
so
he sneezes
inside the guy's dick and explodes the
dude all over the phone oh my god it's
crazy this is the [ __ ] you're sitting
and then you're watching the mushrooms
and this is what you're doing with your
life the guy kicks in the door right
finds him the guy he puts the little
[ __ ] [ __ ] into a bag of
cocaine and shakes it up right he dies
of an overdose
yeah besides dying of an overdose it's
kind of a dream scenario for me i wish i
could just go swim around the bag of
cocaine i might do that tonight to be
honest where's the bag
it might be the way i get over this
hangover from plane drinking this
morning
is cocaine a nice
even if you have a hangover would you
say it
well it's more of if i'm really drunk
thing
you know cocaine's weird now because
the day of doing it with strangers in a
bathroom is over because you might have
you just can't trust the drugs anymore
we're having to run around with drug
testing kids like [ __ ] a police
officer you know what i'm saying we're
like testing [ __ ] with testing strips
yeah because you might die yeah it's
[ __ ] [ __ ] up dude guy what is so
cool when you just bump into a stone
cold stranger at a bar he's like want to
hit a bumper like [ __ ] yeah he was like
the mountain fairy he would just be in
there pulling little mountains of coke
on the end of a key or a [ __ ] car you
didn't know this dude you were just like
thank you mountain fairy i'll take
another little hill and you're just
hitting them with them and y'all are
[ __ ] partying in the bathroom you
don't [ __ ] know each other and then
you leave you're like i just did some
killer blow with that dude in the
bathroom dude's [ __ ] off he was
raking him out son and now you're dudes
in the bathroom like you want to hit
some blow and i'm like
i want to see you do a whole eight ball
first first show me you can do it yeah
and how long have you been doing this
blow you might have already got
accustomed to the amount of fentanyl in
it and that might not be
you know a lot of people that are
dealing with that [ __ ] like the overdose
[ __ ] because i know it's happening a lot
like everywhere man we had a really bad
few years in nashville especially with
old friends from the neighborhood that
kind of went from pills to shooting [ __ ]
and just you know
that whole culture is just out here
they're like uh
i watch way too much random [ __ ] on
youtube but there's this guy named dark
white underbelly you watch your [ __ ] so
he interviews like prostitutes and like
murderers and all kinds of crazy [ __ ]
but dude
in la like in [ __ ] uh where's the
homeless people that skid row yeah
they're all like they don't want i was
just gonna say where are they not no no
they don't want um normal drugs like
they're they specifically are smoking
fentanyl like they're like
proof they're like fentanyl proof these
[ __ ] crackheads but i think it's like
everything else like once your body has
felt it and gets it in certain amounts
you can but i think it's just i don't
get it at all i don't understand so it's
definitely put a damper on my cocaine
i've heard i'm in the prime of my career
i should be out here living like [ __ ]
jerry buss in the 70s [ __ ] 80s i
should be out here just fine
me and my wife should just be out here
[ __ ] [ __ ] and [ __ ]
doing just [ __ ] just
piles of cocaine every night and
drinking scotch for breakfast
and instead we're having to run around
like she's probably got a std and that
cocaine's probably got phenol in it
jesus yep just wrong wrong area that
makes me think about this have you ever
thought about what the backstage looked
like at a concert in the 70s and 80s oh
oh yeah i mean it was amazing dude there
was not a camera in sight yeah i just
imagined topless women running around
and passing out heroin kids
heroin kids uh [ __ ] dick pills
shout out
yo here's a blue chew
and a [ __ ] shot of heroin right and
they're just running around everybody's
just origin by the way
go to bluetooth.com promo code bootleg
and get your first month free there you
go baby go to the bluetooth.com and look
at see i'll run your promos for you you
got a bad read i'll do it with you right
now the blue chews work they do work i
know shoals
souls convinced me too have you tried
one yeah i took a blue shoe you wake up
in the morning that dick hard the wind
blows and it's like hello you have that
piss boner you gotta get out in the
morning yeah and i i just i need all the
help i can get in that department hey
man
as belly goes out it goes in it's like a
turtle just receding it's just getting
the [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] bad dude it's disappearing
and smelling bad i'm not looking for
sure
it's so bad it's just
it's [ __ ] horrible
maybe that's why we're not having orgies
backstage doing cupcake too the turtle
don't come out much when he does he
smells like a swamp it's just
[Laughter]
i can't believe my wife loves me i
[ __ ] have such a disappointment
[Laughter]
yeah i thought about this 80s thing the
other day because we were at a festival
and i'm backstage and i looked around
and there was like a dude from another
rock band complaining about having a
peanut allergy
and asking where the vegan options were
and if there was any peanuts in the room
at all what a [ __ ] and i'm like
[ __ ]
vincent neal would be sickened by you
it's like [ __ ] the guy in nickelback
or something
you know what's somewhere crazy i talked
to chad from nickelback and he's
actually one of the cool ones
i think nickelback gets a bad rep
they're kind of like the go-to band to
be like they're they're gay
listen but if you don't think but no
one's gayer than creed yeah
[Laughter]
i tell you what
i can say this i don't have a creed song
i bump very often at all but i can tell
you that rockstar still [ __ ] oh yeah
yeah and nickelback might make the best
white strip club music ever you're going
to do a white strip club and a chick
that's the size of the rail of that
light over there it's just slow
thrusting
look at this photograph
that's like a [ __ ] go-to at the white
strip club yeah
it's worth saving
by the way have you done the gathering
of the judges i've done it nine times
i have tripped acid all nine times i was
there the year they threw [ __ ] at tila
tequila
i was there it was awesome it was so
incredible it was the greatest moment
ever she got on stage and they started
booing her and then she just like
leaned into it like pulls her top off
and starts shaking her titties and like
she thought like juggalos would be like
oh well no we're gonna cheer for that
these are juggalos [ __ ]
everybody out here shaking their titties
and [ __ ] smells like my pecker it's
[ __ ] you know i'm saying
not because i'm a juggalo at heart not
because juggalos think but because
they've been camping for five days in
the woods in [ __ ] 80 to 98 degree
weather and doing drugs listen right and
you're shaking your attention they just
start throwing just bottles of [ __ ] and
piss at her
i'd like to point out i haven't met many
juggalos that i've came away from being
around and said they smell nice yeah
well listen i've got some of the best
drugs and weed on earth i can tell you
this
if i have a car oh sorry about that just
pop it right on i've been [ __ ] with
this to the point i was trapping trying
to break it just take it off yeah no i
want to plug the cash you know
i might have did it though there it's up
there look at me [ __ ] let's go son
if i break down on the side of the road
and i see a car pull up with that
hatching man oh you're good
thank you the most
genuine people that's why i said i'll
always be a juggle at heart those people
are the best people on earth and you
want to get good acid
you call a [ __ ] juggalo if you don't
call a dude that's a [ __ ] deadhead
if you got to either have
a teddy bear tattooed on you or a
hatchet man tattooed on you to give me
any psychedelic except for you kev it's
literally it's so funny
there's like teachers now with like
hatchet man tattoos and [ __ ] oh yeah for
sure that we're just tripping balls
watching tia tequila get absolutely
jerseys yeah oh yeah just [ __ ] you
know remember those jinkos oh yeah you
had a pair you mean no no but you never
had a pair of shoes my cousin was a big
juggler i'm guilty i had a pair of
jenkins do you remember like the bottom
of them how like how crusty they'd get
because they dragged into your shoes oh
my god i love crusty stuff though you
could probably tell but you could put a
whole two liter in the pocket yeah oh
you could put anything listen yo yo this
is the advantage of being fat i have
this pocket right here in my denim
jackets i can fit a bottle of tequila in
smuggle it anywhere wow true story i am
always i normally have a bottle of
tequila on me
when you were at the liquor store
earlier i thought that's what you were
getting so i didn't bring any no i had
to get water oh
is there a was there a drug bridge at
the gathering yeah it was the best
bridge ever so so there's like so at the
gathering of the juggalos i don't know
if it still is the case i gotta take you
but there's a
supposedly like a free drug bridge or
some [ __ ] right and i heard there's like
a [ __ ] hut
dude it's a community
[ __ ] fast wonder what that smells
like in there though the [ __ ]
well
i have a reference point
but it's just did you ever [ __ ] [ __ ]
at uh the gathering i've never [ __ ] in
the [ __ ] hut at the gathering but you're
[ __ ] i [ __ ] at the gathering
the gathering [ __ ] it is awesome yeah
it will change listen so they used to
have a cave and rock illinois the only
way to get there was during the day by
ferry
you had to take a ferry or you had to
drive like four hours around the other
way to get there or you could take a
ferry over
some private property so they could do
anything anything it was a complete
[ __ ] chaos it was absolute
lawlessness
you know what the same thing of the
gathering is
mud parks i play mud parks all the time
these festivals these off-road atv parks
they're the gathering for country people
they go out there and camp for four days
and [ __ ] it's lawless they do drugs
they [ __ ]
they [ __ ] drink themselves to sleep
they catch [ __ ] on fire and they ride
[ __ ] four wheelers it is heaven on
earth it is the best experience i've
ever every time i play one i pull up
early i have somebody bring the four
wheelers out we tear [ __ ] up it is a
blast the gathering's the exact same way
it's just like it's like
everybody's there for the music and
peace you don't hear people arguing
right or just well it's like a [ __ ] to
each other juggalo thing if they're it's
like a family oriented fan base right
yeah for sure no they're that's their
whole thing is family yeah it's a dude
i'll take you to one they're a ball i
tried to play this one this year but i
had a scheduling i've been to a
few shows yeah where they shoot faygo
into the crowd yeah yeah that's like the
show they do it the last night too but
they did a they did a tour
tech nine
cottonmouth kings and bones that was one
of the biggest tourists ever own things
in harmony yes what a [ __ ] i saw them
at mesa what was the name of that had a
crazy name too it was like really big
they did mesa amphitheater which is like
6 000 people sold out they were [ __ ]
launching two leaders into the sky of
faygo you know how hard it was to sell
hard tickets back then you couldn't like
you had to advertise like traditional
ways true like it i remember word of
mouth you know i used to always get
i used to always just pick up a new
times which is like a free newspaper in
arizona and you just go in there and see
what shows that was the only way i knew
what shows were coming yeah now it's
like the internet i play yellow wolf has
a [ __ ] one of my favorite gathering
stories ever
they shot a bottle rocket while he was
performing
and he goes at this moment [ __ ] true
yellow or fast and he goes
which they wasn't shooting it like to be
mean it's just a gathering right they're
just [ __ ] over shooting fireworks and
he goes i bet you can't hit me with a
bottle rocket
dude
hundreds of juggalos just start shooting
bottle rockets and yellow wolf he's up
there like dude he's slipping them like
tyson in 84. he's
through moving boom they're whizzing by
he goes haha [ __ ] and he's
rapping while doing it it was like one
of the dopest things i've ever seen
have you heard yellow wolf's rock album
i love it it is so [ __ ] good yes
make me a believer thing is crazy the
video is crazy oh my god the radio
record everything i think i told him i
was like uh this feels like
it just feels like
big feels arena rock yes old school
arena rock yeah it feels like i told him
this the other day i was like i feel
like you should be opening up for like
[ __ ] motley crew or [ __ ] like the
rolling stones like this [ __ ] sounds
like you should be opening for the
rolling stones it's like big [ __ ] big
[ __ ] it's so [ __ ] good and i thought
that was dope for him to do that
to get that loose with that right after
coming off you know
the mile zero project and then the
caskey [ __ ]
yeah shout out to uh shooter jennings
sometimes wire
that is struggles brother uh struggles
uncle struggle okay struggles uncle
shooter is what we call them would you
in struggle do another joint we're doing
another one now you are we're we'll be
putting those out until we're [ __ ]
like grumpy old men
are the grumpy old men movies that'll be
me and struggle putting out projects
when we're 70. i remember the yeah yeah
the grumpy old men was a i remember the
what was the guy's name he one had white
hair and one had that big [ __ ] nose
yeah i forgot the names of it but it's
like well that'll be me in struggle
we'll be like
putting out projects yeah he makes me
feel really fat every time i see him on
instagram listen you want to [ __ ] you
imagine how i feel he looks like a
[ __ ] action figure yeah he's [ __ ]
yeah no i [ __ ] hate him i'm like bro
yeah no i've seen him he's just walking
around with his shirt off [ __ ] doing
he looks like he's a professional cage
fighter he does what the [ __ ] is
happening with you yeah and i couldn't
be doing more of the opposite i'm just
like [ __ ] eating sandwiches and
drinking myself into a coma every night
and [ __ ] waking up with a hangover
and having to eat my way through it the
next day you know saying or blowing
[ __ ] cocaine boogers out i'm having
like the total opposite
moment of my life and struggles having
right now i just rewatched the first uh
episode of uh
[ __ ] snowfall as you see snowfall oh
yes you know like that first episode the
fbi agent
i think a [ __ ] blows cocaine up his ass
and he dies or is the other way no no he
blows cocaine up her ass and she dies
and then he has to clean up the body
i set out to say have you ever snored
cocaine off of a woman's [ __ ] yes how
was that oh incredible
i think i did to my wife to be honest
with me my wife you know my wife's sober
now
when we first got together i was the
doctor
yeah shout out to my wife man she's
she is the sober one and but she was
like
a [ __ ]
mad woman
when i first got with her you know i
think the first five times i seen her i
just i just asked her for a bump in a
xanax bar
like in past and i was like you gotta
bump she's like yep and she'd feed me a
[ __ ] just big old [ __ ] hogger and
then i'd be like later that night i'd
bump into her again at some bar or
something because you know i'd be like
you got a xanax she's like yep she's
like she was like a pest dispenser of
drugs that's [ __ ] great yeah
literally she was just like the [ __ ]
she was the mountain fairy in the
bathroom right she was back you know she
was just running around just feeding
everything if you do too much cocaine
it's hard to [ __ ] on that right oh well
[ __ ] i mean we've already discussed my
struggles i knew i would need a blue two
times two and a miracle hills and it's
[ __ ]
is it harder to [ __ ] when you're the
size you are
in terms of just like the geometry of
the situation it's like playing [ __ ]
uh twister
left foot on yellow right hand on red
move this here set this on your back
he'll say it turn this way i mean i feel
like you were you did have an error
though where you lost a lot of weight i
did yeah yeah i did and believe it or
not let's be clear i'm i'm i'm down like
25 30 pounds i joke it's great i'm
taking my health series i go see my
cardiologist every three months but
you're trying to get yourself i'm losing
the weight at a good rate i don't want
to lose it too fast because of the heart
but people are going to want to see
nothing bad happen to you like look i
used to do cocaine and sip lean y'all
i'm going to be okay you're going to be
fine don't worry about me i'm i'm all
right i'm being facetious more often
than not but um
yeah it's like [ __ ] i lose the weight
again pandemic just [ __ ] did it to me
you know just [ __ ] me too i never had
to sit still i lost like 40 pounds oh
dude
yeah right i gained 40 pounds you know
what's crazy you were like me though i
never had to sit
yeah it was like the first time from
years of touring that god was just like
no you're going to just sit here you go
you have to cancel some shows too oh
[ __ ] a whole tech nine tour that's right
57 cities or something tour never
happened it's the best tour that never
took off wow i forgot that [ __ ]
heartbreaking now we have a gold record
together that we've never even performed
creature's gold gold yes sir me him and
calico jeez
it's [ __ ] nuts i forgot and then he
had to redo it with ritz yep shout out
to ritz and shout out to ritz still
[ __ ] out there slugging still out
there
race is going to ritz man i can tell you
this ain't nobody out rapping ritz
i don't disagree i mean he knows this he
knows how i feel about him no ain't
nobody out rapping ritz man
you know when when he's in his bag ain't
nobody [ __ ] with that dude man i just
hope one day ritz can have an honest
bio book because he has some of the
craziest stories that he can never tell
on camera oh it's [ __ ] it's a wild
boy that no that dude's [ __ ] nuts i'm
a little crazy he's a
he's a lunatic
lunatic yeah he's crazy bro it's been
cool watching that whole scene and
everybody grow the way they have for
sure for sure even like a guy like
caskey you know caskey's uh he records
here he just really just did this while
i'm here yeah
i love love what he's doing um
you know y'all talked about on the
podcast obviously we all got in a weird
spot because caskey ended up
like dissing some other dudes that we
associate with in the circuit and it's
like
i'm glad i'm glad this somehow
paralleled into this cause you know what
hurts me about that whole situation
is watching a bunch of really good dudes
that don't know each other
have a problem with each other and me
knowing every one of them personally
and being like y'all are all really good
dudes though like if you guys ever
actually hung out yeah like if you knew
adam calhoun's heart
and that dude is a [ __ ] sweetheart
man he's a good [ __ ] father
he's a dedicated you know he's just like
a good dude that's fair you know what
i'm saying like it's like if you knew
that about him like how much he just
celebrates other people winning and how
much he's one of the first texts i get
every time i do something cool
you him there's a group of people that
every time something even looks cool
he's one of the first texts like such a
sweetheart
casca watched since he was a kid
like that he's a great dude like
caskey's not a bad yeah i don't know
what the
root of their issue is i think that uh
you know what i think man that's what i
truly think i think that
during the pandemic
uh
and i'm
i'm like a really
independently thinking guy i kind of
consider myself like more in like the
joe rogan lane of politics right
socially liberal
i wanna i wanna i wanna protect my
family i wanna be able to you know
obviously within reason have access to
weapons and you know i do feel like
18 year old kids who just graduated high
school shouldn't be able to go buy two
ar-15s without taking a class or
something right
i'm not saying take the guns right just
like you know maybe go through a course
before you get something like that but
i do think that like a guy like adam
calhoun
who i didn't know anything about except
for
when caskey because i'm close with
caskey right of course and then the
first thing i just see is all this
politics [ __ ] this you know the mag of
[ __ ] and to me
i'm like all right well
anybody who rides that it'd be like if
there was a joe like a rapper riding for
joe biden i'd be like crazy right what
the [ __ ] wrong with you for sure and
so you know and that's why like
i i like when i saw that i'm just like
yeah dude like i i don't know i don't
get that [ __ ] and and to me like at the
end of the day people make music for all
types of audiences right and you know i
think a guy like struggle is like a
perfect example of somebody who may feel
however he feels but he's just making
music and he's not like
making
it in a divisive way that makes fans
feel
that they have to
shoot like if does that make sense what
i'm saying no totally it's like
that makes more sense than anything
and i live in the complete opposite
world of everybody
i don't have an opinion about this [ __ ]
at all
like i hate our government i hated our
government with every president we've
had since i was like 14 because they
charged me as an adult
for a crime i committed when i was
[ __ ] 15 years old they took every
right i have away from and because of
that i am personally protesting our
government i have been forever right
it's like i don't give a [ __ ] i think
it's all
a divide and conquer thing i think a
two-party system is just meant for
failure
right
so i don't get them wrapped up but none
of that [ __ ] um but my thing is too is
that
this is i tell you this story and this
is where it changed my perspective
my brother's here he knows this to be
true
my father
was
i don't think i've ever said this
publicly my father was
a progressive man he probably leaned a
little liberal in his older age right
my uncle was a progressive man that
leaned a little conservative in his
older age they grew up together three
years apart best [ __ ] friends from
birth right 70 in their 70s
my father was more of a methodist church
kind of man which is
a kind of portion of a catholic thing
not a portion but it rides that
offensive kind of direct to the
scripture
real stand-up prey simple you know my
uncle at the time especially was more of
a pentecostal guy which is more of you
know
you know there's a big difference right
um
one day when my dad was dying i said
how have you and uncle beef have been
best friends for all these years
and y'all don't agree
about anything
my father set me straight he said what
are you talking we don't agree about
anything
he said we slightly disagree about two
things
we agree about a thousand things right
he's like i don't understand why the
world wants to talk about the two things
they don't agree about
instead of the thousand things we can
make progress with that we do agree
right
and that just changed the way i look at
life you know what i'm saying it's like
immediately i look past it so i guess
it's like even with the [ __ ] i don't
think
i'm old school enough to think that you
know
i don't know what i think about politics
being the music right it's been around
as long as we've been around we have
public enemies
public enemies making protests music
rage against the machine it's been
happening of course so
you know it's funny i was thinking about
it like
when adam and them first started rapping
i would look at that like oh dude these
dudes are
like this isn't protest music they're
agreeing with the government
and then there's a
regime switch in america right the the
part the political parties changes and
suddenly it's like oh that's protest
music now
and that just showed me how unstable the
foundation of america is in itself
right yeah i mean i guess with that dude
i you know
i don't know much about um
his whole catalog i guess i've just seen
a few well he's got some stuff that's
really dope but then i've seen like uh
there's but then there's other guys like
you know i'll see like uh the dude from
florida uh what's that dude's name the
maga rapper dude
yeah now that to me to me that [ __ ] is
just corny it's corny to me because i
know what he was doing before he was
doing that he was doing the blue hair
[ __ ] bootleg riff-raff [ __ ] i lived
for sure saint pete no 100 he was doing
like the uh the white rick ross thing
right yeah it was like
his angle and
to each their own to me it's like
low-hanging fruit for sure and it's like
the artist the artistic integrity is
like yo you're kind of like
putting all your eggs in this basket
right but that basket has a ceiling
that's this high for sure no i guess
when you've been making shitty rap music
for as long as that guy has any fandom
you're gonna be like well i'm making
money over here so i'm gonna lean into
this [ __ ] but to me it's just like
divisive but i do think like i said like
you know it's important like
for me
if i if i don't agree with somebody
on certain [ __ ] i like i have i have
people in my life who will cut people
off based on like their opinion on one
or two things oh yeah and to me that's
never like
uh productive oh it's like and i guess
that that goes back to my thing with
them was like
i know adam outside of the music i know
caskey outside of the music i know
everybody was politically charged in
that moment except for jelly roll cause
[ __ ] our government forever
but
it's one of those things where like i
know these dudes to be good dudes
so you look when that happens and you're
like ah just not necessary i wish i
could get you all together to just like
talk like
responsible dudes like you know what i
mean like y'all have so much like y'all
would actually
have a lot of tons and comments yeah
they're gonna have a [ __ ] hilarious
conversation
um
tom mcdonald's the same way right you
know you're from canada right yeah yeah
he's from canada but he's [ __ ] you
know i don't i don't like again like i
did um because he's independent and i i
i uh
i'm also kind of like like when you know
he does a lot of the youtube rap [ __ ]
like you know
and um
i watched a vlog he did about uh him and
that dude's album
being [ __ ] on billboard
and i watched that because i was
actually interested in that because i'm
like yo as an independent artist that's
crazy what that dude's doing i might not
[ __ ] with his music right but it's
insane the business is built right and
it's like just him and his girl yeah for
sure no that's the [ __ ] i can look past
and i'm like yo this is this respectable
like you know like i might not agree
with like i might not be a fan of like
his [ __ ] like it's just not for me but i
can at least appreciate an independent
artist doing that kind of [ __ ] that
shit's crazy he's got a record he put
out called scars it's like a rock kind
of driven record that's [ __ ]
incredible songwriting
and that's kind of where i live with
everybody right i'm just always looking
for
i don't know i guess i'm a songwriter so
i'm kind of overwhelmed and all that
other [ __ ] anyway so i'm like does he
have a song i thought was written really
well and adam's got a few cass he's got
a lot yellow wolf's got more than
probably anybody struggle's got a ton
these are dudes that i'm just like ritz
that i can just look at and be like yo i
don't
you know i don't give a [ __ ] if you
were the biggest buying supporter on
earth this song [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying like this i tell you this much
it's like listen r kelly's a piece of
[ __ ]
i love his music you're not going to get
me to quit listening to our wish i agree
you just can't do that to me dude i'm
sorry cancel me
[ __ ] it how about this somebody from the
artist somebody cover it then
but don't take a song that i played at
funerals away from me because this man's
a scumbag somebody cover it like don't
tell me something about michael jackson
and the human nature is one of my
favorite songs ever
you know somebody cover it up if there's
a better version out there i'll bump it
you're saying that's for sure but it's
like man that [ __ ] suck dude i've
cried dozens of tears that i wish it's a
great record i love our i mean r kelly
is probably my favorite r b singer ever
outside of him being a piece of [ __ ]
strictly discography
12 play yeah you know if i didn't know
his name
or know that he pissed on little girls
right or watched the [ __ ] wild r
kelly series that was [ __ ] nuts
oh my god fight if i didn't know that it
was just the voice through the radar i'd
be like yo this [ __ ] slaps yeah it's
it's it's crazy how do you like do you
do you even participate we were talking
about the politics should you vote dude
like are you able to gain because it
being a family yeah man [ __ ] our
government dude you know you know who i
want to vote for who gives me the right
to vote you show me this guy i rally
behind him tomorrow i don't care what
party he's a part of the dude who's like
yo cuz listen
i'm fighting to get into canada
fighting right it's tough tough dude i'm
fight new zealand there's a ton of
places there you can't
go to that
life-changing money is sitting over
there for me get done to get into canada
dude i've got to get a drink minister's
permit i've got to get a lawyer it's
going a hundred thousand dollars to even
see
if it can happen i'm gonna have to just
throw a hundred thousand dollars into a
wishing well dude i just had to pay
like thirty thousand dollars
to get a passport just to be able to
leave america i just had to go clean up
so much [ __ ] just to be able to leave
america for my criminal record it's like
and i love when somebody for sure will
comment on this villains can vote
villains can do this and they're going
to put up a bunch of links that i've
already went to and tried to figure out
tennessee has a zero forgiveness policy
policy for violent offenders
unfortunately i was 15 years old i'm not
proud of it i committed a violent
offense that they deemed hard enough for
me to be charged as an adult
three years before i mean a year and a
half before i [ __ ] grew up
sack of hair on my sack
i was charged as an adult
three years before i was allowed to buy
a pack of cigarettes five years
according to the age thing now which i
just found out yesterday you have to be
21 to buy cigarettes now that's how much
i don't give a [ __ ] about policies and
politics i miss that completely right
but
three years for it
ultimately what i'm getting at here is
because of something i did when i was a
child the government has taken away tons
of rights for mine the right to vote
getting homeowner insurance was next to
impossible renting houses renting
buildings to work out of studios
there's so many things associated with
if you're
[ __ ] that's like when people they
always say like you almost have to lie
on a job you have to for sure so it's
like i go through all these struggles
and then you want me to talk about like
you should speak up about politics you
don't want to hear my rant [ __ ]
[ __ ] our government it [ __ ] me [ __ ]
me [ __ ] me i think we're just like in
a place where the far
the far right and the far left
are
controlling the narrative and dividing
the country that
a country that most people agree on more
[ __ ] than they don't for sure but the
extreme opposite of each side is so
[ __ ] crazy yeah that it's like are
are we in the [ __ ] episode of the
[ __ ] family guy or something
the hardest thing to watch it goes back
to just divine conquer it's all divisive
all divisive man any any system is that
way it's just it's it's made to eat us
from the inside out
and it's just getting worse though i
feel like it's getting worse yeah it's
only going to get worse that's crazy man
and i'll start speaking more publicly
about how i feel about politics when i
[ __ ] they start making [ __ ] right by
us mm-hmm and that's just how i feel i
feel like everybody's i'm just i don't
know i'm bitter i hold a grudge in
florida if you're a felon you can vote
yeah i mean you can in tennessee if you
have a forge a forgivable felony
the violent thing yeah it's like i have
to get a governor's pardon which i'm
working on i'm talking to bill i mean
you're kind of you know you're you're a
big guy now yeah it's like i work in
good circles we have a democratic mayor
in nashville we're friends we get along
well nice i have a republican governor
we're friends and we get along with i do
a lot for the community i'm always
trying to push the ball forward i'm big
i'm donating 100 of the money from the
bridgestone arena show to at-risk youth
i'm building a
music center inside of the juvenile
downtown wow and we're putting together
with the youth impact rear shout out to
robert share we're building a uh
aftercare program that kids will be corn
appointed to if they get charged as
juveniles i'm fixing to put my money in
my mouth it's gonna be a lot of them i
want to make a big difference you're
selling out your hometown and then
putting that money right back in 100
that's big and i'm matching it
on top of that
that's great i'll tell you what the
number is off camera that's a lot man i
mean i'm sure it's a lot it's a lot
sounds like about a quarter million
dollars it's
you're warm yeah but not hot that's
crazy that much i mean it's it's a lot
of money that's beautiful man yeah what
is that because that's what i'm
passionate about right so when people
are like what do you think about you
know whatever's happening in the world
today i'm like i don't know man i'm just
trying to figure out a way that i can
help some 14 year old kid not throw his
life away at 14.
not make the same mistakes i did yeah
dude they wouldn't let me in the
community college because of my felonies
what i had a community college that
couldn't get me the the money
because of my felonies
that [ __ ] is great you know you're
talking about dude i was [ __ ] 15 man
i mean thank god it worked out the way
it worked out for me but yeah dude i
could have been a [ __ ] doctor or
something i don't know you know how's
the limit the way i'm driven i could
have been a [ __ ] brain surgeon you
didn't do anything i'm helping more
people doing music so you think that you
catching that felony at that age
put you on a path for sure and my big
problem with this is
you're not talking about a decision that
like
adult makes adults make right we're not
talking about
like the revolving door of a grown man
who needs to change his life like you're
talking about a kid like these kids
don't know any better
they're just products of their
environment they're just trying to
figure out what's next for them that's
[ __ ] [ __ ] up
they don't get that there's another
opportunity i didn't realize
there's no way i was in my mid-20s
before i realized how much i [ __ ] up
at 15.
does that make sense like before my
brain could actually go oh my god i like
really [ __ ] what if you don't mind
sharing what happened it was a robbery
case okay
it was a robbery case
and uh we were just kids you know the
saddest part is we were robbing a guy
for weed
but one of the other guys in there
wasn't a weed dealer and had some money
in a watch or something we were like we
were just [ __ ] neighborhood kids man
we're doing
it doesn't make it right right i'm
embarrassed by it i never talk about it
the first podcast ever said what the
charge was i'm
extremely embarrassed by this right i'm
nowhere near that man now but
37 year old man 20 [ __ ] one years
later 22 years later i had to explain
that to my home insurance my homeowner
insurance people
that tried to charge me more for being
at risk wow
you know what i mean when you're just
like are you [ __ ] you know
i had a moment the other day where my
child's mother
bailey bailey's mother's felicia and
she's sober now she was hooked on heroin
for a while i'm proud of she's sober and
me and the wife do everything we can to
offer custody of your daughter you still
do full custody yeah still do me and my
wife um my wife made all that happen
bunny and her really close bunny and
felicia bailey's mother and she calls us
and goes hey i'm trying to move closer
to bailey
i'm a felon can you get us a place
can i put a place in your name and i
don't think twice i'm like yeah for sure
i got you dude i got whatever you know
i'll go send an application over i feel
like right now
i forgot i'm a felon
so it [ __ ] fires back on me and then
she can't get now we're double down and
[ __ ] so we got to find a new place and
put it in bunny's name you know what i
mean it's like i've been
i haven't been on the lease of any house
that i didn't own ever
you know what's crazy is when me and my
wife first moved to cali
i had a
a misdemeanor
and she had
some dui [ __ ] right and you would have
thought that we were murderers the way
people were like denying our [ __ ]
our our [ __ ] yeah like it was like what
the [ __ ] yeah no for sure it's crazy no
it's [ __ ] our system is [ __ ] in so
many ways yeah and i feel like if you're
a felon it's almost like having a like
the scarlet letter in society
right it's like dude like you really
really almost is like impossible for you
to really have like a normal [ __ ]
life you really need help from other
people to like get [ __ ] or to like you
need someone to take a chance give you
an opportunity getting good jobs
do you know what's crazy is that i
couldn't be in the medical field if i
wanted to
there's like four or five industries
that just
don't accept yourself even if you get
the job and maybe you want to be a
supervisor or a manager
you can no there's a wall even if
there's jobs that'll let you get there
it's like no we just never move up
because they look at you you're a
[ __ ] felon no it's [ __ ] it's as
wrong as it can be um
it's sad yeah i think um
that's some broken [ __ ] man yeah like
there's like no forgiveness like no
societal forgiveness
i get it if you like [ __ ] you know or
a [ __ ] creep or you did something
yeah sure but like i say it all the time
i think [ __ ] pedophiles should be
shot on national tv every friday for our
enjoyment it's a great [ __ ] i think
they should tell us a story they should
show us the family's pain they should
show us the weirdo and we should get to
watch them be headed that we should have
we should they should sell it like
pay-per-views and then give that money
to the family i'd watch every friday i
pay every friday they get 20 bucks out
of me every friday to watch them i had a
pedophile right you know what i'm saying
if it went like you know trust me i'm
not like i'm not i'm not you know i'm
just on the justice reform as far as
like the decision of course especially
if you do some stupid [ __ ] as a kid
for sure yeah it's like come on dude
yeah if you stay i think if you give me
an opportunity opportunity to restitute
it out yeah like
let me go give these dudes whatever they
think they lost times 50.
and then square it up with these dudes
that were really robbed 22 years ago and
then let me you know like make me i
don't care if i have to work for it just
give me a [ __ ] option like just don't
say no man it's hard state policy you
get zero forgiveness for that
or like if you're out of the system long
enough it like
doesn't show up i don't know for sure
something where yeah it's just whatever
so what is next obviously jimmy kimmel
is a big deal i'm sure you're excited
for that but what about just in terms of
i know you were for a while were are you
technically independent are you still i
don't
know
situation so i have a deal with broken
bow records which is bmg which i looked
up that dicky plaque and thought about
that
um and uh it is a deal but i did
maintain ownership of my masters which
is huge it's a big deal it's um
the deal is incredible and the deal is
so incredible that i'm not allowed to
talk about it that's [ __ ] but the
deal is incredible it's awesome it's a
great deal i'm happy and i don't know a
lot of people in record deals that are
happy most people aren't yeah and i've
been completely independent my whole
career so i know the other side of that
happiness and
i'm happier now yeah you know they've
they've done everything they said they
were going to do times too i think
they're worth every penny we pay them
you know i'm i just i am in love with
this deal
and is there going to be a big uh are
you going to be announcing a tour
anytime soon
no you know we're touring i'm shining
down later this year i got a bunch of
brantley gilbert dates we're like on the
road non-stop stills i know you're doing
a lot i got shows in florida thursday
and friday of this week i'll literally
fly straight from
you know burke chrysler's podcast to go
do a show
is the plan um
yeah i'm going to do over 100 shows this
year i'm going to announce a big next
year will be a big proper tour for me
though it'll be like you're headlining
your big headlining i mean obviously
you've had a bunch of headlining tours
but this will be like the headlining
tour yeah for sure because what is like
if you were to get booked like what what
do you what do you say is like your
average cap like it for a solo jelly
roll show if someone books you five to
12 000 now [ __ ] crazy man yeah
for sure
few markets we might still play 35 and
fours but that's so big i i suspect that
if we don't play the uh
i suspect that we'll either play the
honda center when we come back or we'll
play the
palladium two nights in a row
that's my guess that's my guess now
that's fire
it's my guess that's my my hope god
willing
we go straight to the hollywood bowl or
something next summer
how's la as a market for you i'm anxious
to see because la's
i don't come out here enough but i do
know that
like northern california cali country is
a big market for me
that's for sure we're doing aftershock
this year in sacramento oh [ __ ] the rock
festival so that'll be huge hopefully
that'll bring some ass i just don't come
out here enough yeah you don't man it's
been a while it's rough man
it's a big travel dude it is a it is a
hike yeah it's a big truck it's like
five hours four yeah about four hours
and 45 minutes in the air
it was rough hmm
you first class yeah yeah gotta get that
first class yeah i mean i'm too fat to
sit anywhere else on that blind date
that much did they charge it twice
if i had to get two seats if i do it any
other way
oh really i don't have to but i do just
because i respect you know i don't want
nobody pushed up on me neither yeah
like no matter what you got a stranger
cuddling on your left and yeah it's like
either way i want to be as comfortable
as possible i just don't like the
concept of flying anyways which is why i
got just blackout drunk today doing it
it's just a weird [ __ ] thing to me
the worst is when you eat an edible on a
going on a flight thinking that it's
going to like help you go to sleep i'm
playing the honda center this year by
the way you got to come out hopefully
shine down yeah we're doing a
a big spot in san diego too
soma
sounds right i'll look at the dates but
we got a lot of [ __ ] coming right around
here have you ever had a
we ate an edible on a plane and freaked
the [ __ ] out
i have a eat at edible and freak the
[ __ ] out once a week moment
planes not planes just where i just over
serve myself you know i'm saying where
there is a thin line because like even
this i can eat these and i eat too many
it'll get wild but i know
you know i can kind of
edibles like a little crazier than
shrooms if you do too much you eat too
much of them it gets [ __ ] weird it's
all anxiety and it almost like
you can't do anything no
[ __ ] no it's like paralyzing listen man
it it turns into a psychedelic spiritual
experience fast
did i ate some rick simpson oil pills
the other day yeah did we talk about
this on the phone oh this is a great
story too
i come home really drunk
and the wife's out of town and i hop on
the game i'm playing like call of duty
or something like five in the morning
and i had a rick simpson oil pill
like
rso
i take it i don't think nothing of it
i'm so drunk i forgot i took it so i
look over
and i take another
one 30 minutes later i'm so lit
i take a third one
i only know the number because i had
four
and i woke up with one
so this is me assuming this is me like
reverse engineering how my night went
south right right
at one point my niece comes and wakes me
up on the couch i'm asleep with a
controller in my hand the sun is blaring
through the house at 7 45 in the morning
i'm shirtless sockless and in my boxers
imagine that look
and she wakes me up and goes
hey are you gonna go to bed
and i stumble to the bed and i fall
asleep sitting up in the bed
watching family guy like back to the
thing
for 10 hours kev
and i woke up with the worst anxiety
i've ever woke up with i felt like my
body was vibrating
everything about it was wrong i took
like the adam sandler longest pitch
remember that'll adam sandler see the
world's longest i mean i pissed for like
three minutes straight it felt like i
pissed for so long i stopped and sat
down
i was tired of standing up trying to
piss my body was vibrating i had
the worst anxiety of my life the entire
next day yeah eating wheat is
i i just had a bad experience about two
weeks ago bro and i don't know if i
could ever i don't know man my worst
nights of my life have been too much
edibles yeah i could eat a lot of
shrooms and like i'll [ __ ] be it'll
be out there but it but i'll ground
myself yeah
eating weed is dangerous man and it's
not even the same thing as smoking it's
not even close it's like you feel that
stomach churn and you know you [ __ ] up
yeah you feel it in your gut and you're
like oh no this ain't it man this is
fixing and you can also hallucinate yes
i've hallucinated yeah i the worst time
i've ever had i ate a cake pop
on my way to
yellow wolf and ritz's show in phoenix
and
this was like er 2013
12 something like that and uh
i was like new to eating weed so i
didn't know anything about it so i was
like oh it's a cake pops like the whole
thing i guess i was only a quarter of it
oh yeah it was like 100 milligrams that
[ __ ] up how they do that to you they
give you 200 milligrams and something
this big and they're like just eat a
sweater so i decided to ask you so i
didn't think much of it you know um
and it i interviewed ritz on the bus and
uh
they didn't hit me right
and then he was going to to go on stage
and i was in the crowd and it hit me
like a ton of bricks at once and i
couldn't move my legs i was stuck in a
standing position
bro i could have you ever been so high
in a place with a bunch of people where
you could look across the room full of
thousands of people and hone in on
someone's conversation yes from very far
away yes so i felt like [ __ ] i had
like super powers
and then i look on stage and ritz is
performing and garfield the cat
is the cartoons up there
with like slot machine dollar sign eyes
going and i was just like
my boy gio was with me and i was like
bro do you see the cat
on stage
and i couldn't move i was stuck bro oh
my and then i was puking everywhere oh
yeah and then everything that could have
happened
what was the name of uh wolf's uh
[ __ ] extremely aggressive road
manager
brooklyn brooklyn that was his name yeah
so i'm like on the side of the stage
[ __ ] tripping the [ __ ] out right all
the random crazy [ __ ] that could happen
in front of somebody who was tripping
happened this dude brooklyn pulls some
dude off from the crowd drags him to the
side he's two feet away from me just
beating the [ __ ] out of this [ __ ] guy
and i'm just like
bro it's crazy yeah now brooklyn was
[ __ ] wild he didn't look like he was
wild wild boy he was aggressive normal
looking guy yes sir just [ __ ] did not
look like the guy that was [ __ ]
pulling the files on you for sure
all the time all the [ __ ] time yeah
yeah so you gotta and obviously you got
music out now but what's like what's
coming the rest of the year oh dude i'm
speaking of brooklyn sadness i've got
bobby straight edge on tour me now shout
out to bobby good guy got straight edge
out there it's been awesome
his first weekend was last weekend it
was incredible yeah he felt good to have
the homie back he just did the tech tour
too
he's road managing one of our buses um
dude i'm cooking
you know i got a i got you know probably
20 30 40 songs on my phone that i feel
great about i mean you know how typical
songwriter i got 100 songs in my phone
but i'm sure the collaboration
opportunities are getting bigger for you
too they are and i'm really really kind
of reaching out for what i want to do
and i'm just taking my you know what i'm
doing with this album i've never done
i'm kettle cooking it mm-hmm it's it's
so cool first dude is in the kettle pot
dude i'm not putting this one on the
skillet
i got this one in the smoker this ain't
on the grill you know what i mean when i
pull this one out it's gonna fall off
the bone baby
and that's my goal you know what i mean
i'm gonna really i'm like obsessing
about songs
like obsessing about them so has the the
country industry is a very
uh
it feels like there's they're very like
it's like this right yeah have they
embraced you so far so good man you know
what this is helping me some good old
boys club type [ __ ] kind of there's some
good old boy club [ __ ] there there's
some gatekeepers but it's like
i think that country music has been
missing what we bring to it that's what
i was telling struggle the other day
because we're kind of working on a
country record with him well he's
working on a country record i'm trying
to talk i'm going to put it out
but
they haven't had
the kind of like raw authenticity and
outlaw [ __ ] that we bring to countryman
that's what the 70s since the 70s
they've had versions of it like my boy
brantley gilbert that came in the early
2000s you know but it's like
they haven't had it in so long
that it's like really authentic right
you know yeah like somebody who just
doesn't give a [ __ ] you know and it's
like and they know i'm a good dude like
at heart they know their story
you know my parenting my ref my
relationships people that have been
around me forever know that i'm not a
bad human
but they also know that i'm a bit of a
wild card and don't give a [ __ ] and they
love they kind of love it
they love that there's going to be a
clip that's going to come out of this
podcast where i'm talking about my
pecker smelling bad right it's like you
know what i mean like where
traditionally it'd be like there'd be a
publicist in a room in a country
interview like what the [ __ ] cut it
right now i want to watch you delete
that part where they just kind of know
that i'm always going to be a little bit
of a loose cannon and that's credit to
jonathan loba the head of broken bow
records for president
look you'll meet him this week
and i can't wait for you to meet him but
loba's got my back
he's like look man we know we we're not
mistaken with who we signed
so every now and then somebody will kind
of ruffle some feathers about something
i say that's wild and lo will just be
like look that's our guy we knew we know
we knew we know jesus
you're not a robot bro
for sure yeah yeah i didn't start the
interview with i grew up in a town with
300 people right outside of
you know yeah i feel like the country
[ __ ] this [ __ ] is so overly packaged
yeah it feels very like
purple like um like like everything so
on purpose and so like unorganic it's
like well there's a lot of there's a lot
of
people it's changing now
because country music radio is getting
bold and not afraid which is awesome but
there was a long time where it was
packaged right like find the guy who has
the right look decent voice hook him up
with hit songwriter hook him up with hit
producer hook him up with stylist dress
them a certain way
give him media training send him on a
radio tour the nashville version of
k-pop
100
right and then you send them on a media
tour and then
insert big record here mm-hmm
you know so yeah and they kept i feel
like a lot of those country guys come
and go yeah
100 yeah
hundred percent like who's the new well
it's also weird because country music is
another genre like other genres where
you'll have a dude who will have three
or four number one records that can't
sell out the troubadour and no one knows
what the [ __ ] he looks like clueless and
kate's literally put him on the radio
like hey your guy who sung you these
five songs in the last two years playing
they relate
they love you do they know the [ __ ] you
are that's the same [ __ ] with the rap
[ __ ] that's why i tell people i'm like
yo like
dude just because you got hits don't
mean people
what really tells you is how are your
heart tickets can you make people care
can you make people give a [ __ ] about
you enough to where they'll spend their
hard-earned money to come 100
perform their art and it's important
that you take that money serious right
it's like you know what i think about
before i do shows i look at the line
every night when i go do a video
and i think about how much of a pain in
the ass it is for me and my wife to have
a date night um
right
like how hard is it for you and your
wife to have some y'all time
it is tough right it is tough so busy so
much [ __ ] going on so think about you
went out of your way to make this night
happen
like this is your date night this is
your [ __ ] yeah like you're here to have
a great time
this is the highlight of your month baby
this is it yeah this might be the
highlight of the year yeah this might be
the only time y'all got a babysitter in
a hotel room fill the car up put on your
best outfit i imagine her ordering
clothes i imagine her standing in the
mirror curling her hair i imagine him
sitting on the couch wishing that [ __ ]
would hurry wow i imagine all these
scenarios i've been in
you're like you know i think i gotta i
gotta deliver i think about that yeah i
literally like obsessed about that
thought wow i think about the dude who
saved the money to get the ticket and
then saved a little extra cash for some
beer and some merch and didn't tell his
old girl so she thinks they're on a
strict budget he walks in with a little
little chunk on him she don't know he's
got oh baby i've got a little extra
bread look check this out grab your
shirt let's go get some
get we're going to drink all night [ __ ]
it no we don't want the cheap beer get
us get us a bud light
most artists don't approach it that way
they're entitled man i just look at it
like man that's correct i know because i
know how much of a pain in the ass and
i'm
financially stable and i know how hard
it is for me and my wife to just make a
night
i can only imagine you know think about
the man this you know i mean this dude
had to go argue with his he had to go
bow and kiss the ring of his in-law for
a babysitter
you know what i mean he had to go sit
down with the mother-in-law he hates and
go hey i really really need a night i've
got a chance go see this jelly roll guy
a couple hours up the street i got a
hotel room can you please and the
[ __ ] mother-in-law's got a list of
demands
he's got to cut her grass or some weird
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying i know i
know what's happening so i think about
that [ __ ] before i do a show every night
that shit's crazy most artists should
have that approach man yeah i think
about that in every aspect
all right so
troubadour this week
tomorrow tomorrow we're gonna [ __ ]
the time this comes out the show would
have already happened yeah there'll be
clips out on your instagram stories
jimmy kimmel jimmy kimmel that's out go
watch big tour big tour
putting out i'll probably drop an album
this year november i'm guessing out in
november yeah i'll be rapping on there i
got a rap project i'm working on too i'm
going to drop another rap project like
strictly
i'm not like a reminder roots yeah yeah
for sure every now and then
freestyle um
i feel like was it last year two years
yeah about a year ago i was still doing
everything
i thought i was going to spit here but
you never hit me
well i got treated like a crush
don't don't tell me you tweeted me about
spitting
because i became
ready to spit i probably still spit
really hold on let me just show you what
i tweeted you
[Music]
hold on jelly roll 615.
i said
hold on where's it at
someone tell jelly roll have some bars
for my show on his trip to l.a in june
oh
god about have seen that
i was i was joking with my wife asked me
specifically she was like she was like
are you to go spit i was like
oh my god papa
you're verified on here right not on
twitter i'm on instagram we got to
figure that out on instagram i am i
don't know how to get verified on
twitter i'll figure it out i feel like
it just happens i'll look into it
wow it has to be away
missed out on that one
i'm in town a couple days
well listen man
i'm proud of you buddy
what the [ __ ] playing all right pull
up a beat
i'm super proud of you though i love you
man thanks for having me i've been
wanting to do this i mean a lot of you
let me come in here and talk about [ __ ]
i never talk about and uh i'm i'm just
happy for you man
you're a great guy and i'm glad the
whole world is finally catching on my
jeep let's [ __ ] go boom jelly roll
bootleg [ __ ]